[Music]
we love you
I love
living for that moment with Harrison
Ford you reunite United with him again
what was that like
it was incredible I mean you know that
the first time I reunited with him was
at Disney's d23 the second time
was at the Oscars and for him to present
us you know for best picture just make
that night even even so much more
memorable uh and and I thought I
couldn't love the man more but I I did
what did you say to him just now I said
a lot I forgot I forgot but I mean but
I'm honestly every time I see him uh
he's such a he's such a gracious man
such a humble man and the reason why I
love acting so much is because of him it
gives him that experience that we had on
Temple of Doom so uh so here we are so
many years later my favorite is the way
you Embrace him I mean you have all of
your arms around Tim I can't help myself
every time I see him or Stephen or
George I have to give him a big hug uh
because because of course you know these
men these men changed my life uh and and
who would have thought that you know 13
39 years ago we premiered Indiana Jones
and Temple is doing right next door at
the main Chinese Theater and so to be
able to be here tonight is incredible
you deserve every ounce of goodness that
has come your way we are so happy for
you gotta ask you where's the Oscar
where do you keep it
it's at home it's at home where our
special special I have I have so much
respect for uh for the Oscars and you
know and honestly I still look at that
statue
with on wonder because I can't believe
it has my name on it so it is it is it
is very high up so it's very hot no one
can touch it well you know I yeah it's
it's uh it it means a lot and I cannot
believe that uh that that it's at home
uh any and he's my new best friend these
Universe are of course yes it should be
congratulations we got to get a big
Harrison Ford thank you so much
I'm so happy for you truly thank you
thank you